[Music]
all right Star Wars fans we need to talk
and this video is going to go across the
board and no it has nothing to do with
the fact that it looks like I'm in a
tropical paradise Star Wars Episode nine
has a new director after parting ways
with Colin Trevorrow and it's JJ Abrams
this is the most divided twitter has
been since yesterday and if you follow
me do it then you know I essentially
glitched on my way to work this morning
yeah I had a meltdown
so as JJ Abrams the darkside or a new
hope of episode 9 when I woke up to the
news I sighed and I was like no this is
way too safe of a choice but maybe not
so much let's go through some of the
pros and cons con JJ Abrams is a safe
choice and yeah he is but is that
necessarily a bad thing
Pro is JJ as safe of a choice as I
thought this morning while the force
awakens has parallels to a new hope I
mean he pushed boundaries with his
castings of Daisy Ridley a female
protagonist and Oscar Isaac and John
boyega Khan the force awakens felt like
a reboot of episode 4 I mean he
recreated but that starts out like
Captain wean etcetera etc but yes you
can argue that the force awakens was a
soft reboot but it's a reboot done in a
way to continue a story and not piss off
an entire fan base if doing a reboot was
the goal JJ Abrams executed that
flawlessly Plus Rian Johnson seems to be
moving away from Empire Strikes Back and
I want to quote one of my Twitter
friends Olivia here who said whatever is
left for Bryan's take could be enough to
add some edge and I think that's a great
point Khan Lucasfilm has not made any
diverse choices in terms of directors
look this is true we constantly throw
directors like Ava Duvernay and patty
Jenkins into our short list but at this
point only white dudes have directed
Star Wars and that needs to change
sooner rather than later
there's no pro to that that needs to
change another Pro is that JJ Abrams
created these new characters he knows
them better than anyone he is the right
person to bring this trilogy full circle
oh and one more Pro this is our chance
to bring back constable Xavi oh I'm
talking to you Heath
so here's my question to you do you like
JJ Abrams coming back to direct episode
9 why or why not chuck it all in the
comments below and I'll hit you with a
fade and a reply if you tweet me at as
Karlsson and make the force be with
[Music]
you